On Sunday indeed, at Monday, I ran the frequencies for trauma and then the frequencies for the
parasite, hilarious. Later in the afternoon, I felt like I was on speed. It was very uncomfortable.
I just talked it up to taking my V vitamins to late the day. I did, however, feel tremendous
release from the trauma frequency and have felt joy for the first time in years. This is huge.
For me in a huge praise report, we'll praise God for that. This morning, I did the trauma and the
hilarious frequency again after also doing the last e-beam. I had not eaten anything, no caffeine,
no albuterol, or no due supplements, the wired speed feeling, like feeling started about 30 minutes
after I finished the frequencies. My pulse was normal, but I am still swirly to my brain and feel
very uncomfortable. Do you have any thoughts on what this might be? Should I do the frequencies
once a day or every other day to prevent this? Yes, so there's times that you can run parasite
frequencies and you could get these symptoms. I think it's from the parasite frequencies. So,
because you can have parasites in your head. The diop can affect this, it can cause this. So, you
could get diop and you could get glutamate release in your brain with a diop and that's probably what's
doing it. So glutamate is an excitatory or a transmitter and that's most likely what's happening.
So, but it's all good, but you can't, you got to be careful on how much you do because you don't
want to overdo it. You have to be able to clear that glutamate out ultimately. So, you've got to
give yourself some time. So, either spread out the times that you do this, meeting like you're
going to do it every three days or maybe you're going to do it once a week or choose to do it for a
less amount of time each time. So, you can stop the program after a period of time and see if that
makes a difference. Like, the program is 20 minutes or you do 10 minutes, you know, you've got to choose,
maybe you only do it once a week, the whole program. So, try to pick and choose what,
and play with what makes you feel better. So, it's all good things, but you've got to let your body detox